[Music]
and porn kills news shows what what does
it kill submitted by puppy from El
Barrio and Mario does the Chihuahua
probably Ponyo Ponyo a little puppy Oh
same thing pretty close
a wife admits to killing her killing
husband after he purchased porn [ __ ]
ality or she should [ __ ] kill who
purchases porn you freaking [ __ ]
watch that [ __ ] for free you sick [ __ ]
what if you wanted to support the artist
no dude you got this so much appreciate
this is not quality if you buy porn or
you download porn you are a sick freak
what if she's like in a poor country and
they only have VHS less in America you
know what do not you I did a sketch
about that about like donating your use
porn to like third world countries that
only have like one porno mag so you said
recycle porn yeah you're just a god to
them yeah yeah just send them all the
old VHS tapes and DVDs you guys like
throwback porn I do sometimes I search
specific I missed us yeah ninety style I
miss it you know like what's the ninety
style like when they looked really poor
knee yeah like the porn star era that
was like I feel like that like the big
titties oh yeah they were millionaires
those the parney era the golden era oh I
guess they did like it then yeah like
creeped me out cause it makes me think
of like my parents and [ __ ] like it's
just like your parents look like your
personal forties not that they look like
point style so I think of them put the
hairstyle in this stuff I don't like how
real the bodies look right now so real
yeah like it's what you naturally give
me that synthetic [ __ ] that I can't get
you like the pornstar look yeah yeah
yeah give me that fake [ __ ] there's a
morbid you watch a lot of porn not a lot
I mean enough to know what I like
because I feel like the 90s was more
real than now like their face and
boobies and everything except for boob
implants but then it does look a little
more natural then oh I think you're
talking about the cam girl stuff
right or the amateur stuff maybe I just
feel like there's so much about right
now it's cuz it still flooded like girls
next door yeah yeah I got another camera
they could just make everything is POV I
hate it
it's stunt sex she's like back in the
90s it was like just simple you got guy
sticks Dick and vagina and they would
call now it's like one chick taking on
like 90 dudes you're just like what is
going on it's too much it is you know
why it's because it became too
accessible so they got bored with all
the same jobs yeah
every [ __ ] time yeah alright so this
story takes place in Arkansas
yep that explains it yeah men corn is
still illegal and probably Arkansas [ __ ]
a donkey but you can't watch porno
there's like some weird rules like the
you can't have a sex style but like
incest is still legal they're cool you
could [ __ ] your first cousin or some
[ __ ] but that's crazy yeah so Patricia
who is 69 years old boom I'll never stop
laughing
Yeah right when she was 69 she could
have waited one more year more clicks
yeah that was our newest year of my life
she's been waiting for that you know she
has been charged with capital murder
after killing her 65 year old husband
named Frank well she's a [ __ ] cradle
robber 90 though you know they would
hello that's hard times look at their
faces
she has pikas chin she Asian she does
look like her you know what Titan looks
like he does it oh wait so capital means
they might give her the death penalty
yeah like it's that really a death I
mean like she just had an awful reaction
well hold on so this is the story so she
said that
she arrived home she walked into the
utility shed he was jacking off to
confront her husband about her
disagreeing his purchase of pornography
okay so you saw like the bill or
something in a popped up maybe I wonder
what the bill like what what did sad
like yeah I know like they call it like
tickle biddies 3 or some sad
funny schoolgirls out come on the first
tip so she canceled the order and then
that's when Frank placed another order
oh my god that's when she asked her
husband to leave the shed but he refused
so she went inside yeah
what is this chicks with dicks number
for the zoo an insider she grabbed her
22 caliber pistol Oh mommy went back to
shed shot her husband twice once in the
head once in the legs good shot dude I'm
[ __ ] all over the head and then she
went back home she's a sniper why the
leg after the head I don't know she
already killed them it's like bang
reported it I thought that was on too
that's all I think if you call 9-1-1 on
yourself you shouldn't be eligible for
the death penalty right you're like I
[ __ ] up come get me I called it on
myself yeah she said she called it she
called the police and she was just wait
suit she was standing in the front yard
waiting for the police to arrest her at
the age of 70 you're still that horny
that [ __ ] sucks dude
I don't want hold on dude what I'm 70 I
don't be horny feet dude senior citizens
have the highest rate of STDs man
they're just getting you these old homes
and boning nobody's pulling out because
you can't get pregnant so we're just
blasting away no no it's crazy so
have sex when you're old - what are you
doing
yeah I'm gagging now though but I'm not
trying to think of my [ __ ] wrinkly
ass you hear all the phrases your mom
says at me go get him tiger
you know what I you know what I did is a
freak so I was looking into the medical
field when I didn't know what kind of
job I wanted to do and somehow I landed
on a form for nurses you know they
talked about the workplace and and
specifically old care right and then in
this exactly that they're talking about
their you know the people that they take
care of just constantly walking and
[ __ ] remember that prostitution ring
at that old Senior Center that they got
caught hold on
what yeah ripping out old ladies oh
you're right at the low-income area and
then they would like give them crack or
whatever something like they were
actually actually had like prostitutes
and people will come in and just [ __ ]
old people hey some people are into that
yeah other old people granny porns big
it is big people just want to get weird
I don't like it there might be snow on
the roof but there's a fire in the
furnace you know what I'm saying oh my
god I just I just don't want to be horny
when I'm old man why I want a clear mind
eventually before I die okay like I just
I just I just thought that was supposed
to die out when you get I don't like
women get progressively more horny as
they get older but mens are live beetles
supposed to die so I was doing it really
actually I'll be able to choose
different time and give oh okay that's
so like we hit menopause and we're dry
as [ __ ] like their testosterone takes
over exactly then you start getting much
talk dealing the way guys do you want to
[ __ ] everything I want to sit on a fire
hydrant and just rub it away we don't
want to [ __ ] all the time anyways but
they got to play defense all right
because that's the job cuz in the role
you're supposed to pick the best male
yeah right but that's gone out the
[ __ ] door right but anyways so like
they want to have sex just as much as oh
I don't know I think times have changed
though like denature your cousin say
something about like the first base now
is [ __ ] and then like yeah
relationship this thing's second base
all the porn that's out there I wouldn't
be surprised man
what yeah it's gotten weird yeah Peggy's
third-base Peggy no way more she nobody
knows what pegging is when a girl [ __ ]
the guy's butt Hawaiian no paintings
when you beat yes that's a Singapore
Singaporean torture tactic that's what
in Singapore they beat you with a dildo
the sexual things there might be there's
just so many different
I could never [ __ ] Bart like that's just
I can't do that
I got a view him as a man he seems sad
right there nah he's I've tried like I
do that I do that if that makes a more
of a man like yeah [ __ ] me you know
instead of oh [ __ ] me it's like pork
[ __ ] this dude she can't do it I can't
do it I mean you tried it
hell no my booty Oh is so sensitive it's
an action that is an exit a little swipe
and credit card and I'm like wait that
looks that looks good no but I can't go
inside because it's like it's like you
know when you get that tremor that that
[ __ ] backs yeah yeah that [ __ ]
spine in the back of the neck like the
devil's around when you talk about ghost
stories this [ __ ] yeah that [ __ ] yes
move on like I get it stop
so when you hear ghost stories the same
feeling you get when you get peg if
something comes close to my butthole I
get to I get whoa it's too sensitive you
know like to get that in there you know
like to get pegged super-powerful guys
oh yeah it's like they're all into the
dominatrix yeah that's what they're
really is because they crush Souls yeah
they're like come on and spit was like
when I watch that show beat Bobby Flay I
go that dude likes to get pegged in the
ass cuz he's he's like at the top of his
game and he likes to crush spirits I'm
like that's a dude who wants to go home
and get pegged and ass by some chick
dressed as like street fighters yeah
down that's like wolf of wallstreet
remember that scene like he liked to get
the candle wax on his butthole and [ __ ]
like that
you remember that see I don't it was
hilarious yeah like a ball gag and [ __ ]
yeah I guess I'm not that successful I
don't want any of that [ __ ] I'm with you
baby
yeah I'm just like to straight-up
old-fashioned eyeball to eyeball stuff
huh all right I walk to the back of the
head is nice okay yeah that's cool what
I bought I bought a missionary like I
love you I love you you know that [ __ ]
it's the widest position ever [ __ ] that
what do you like when I stare at the
back of your head yeah
[Music]